LIGHT ON THE SHOOTING THAT TOOK
PLACE DURING THE RIOTS IN
KENOSHA.
ALL COMING UP.
FIRST WE TURN TO THE COLLECTIVE
WHAT IS A NATIONAL NERVOUS
BREAKDOWN, TEMPER TANTRUM
UNDERWAY AMONG DEMOCRATS.
THEIR ALLIES IN THE MEDIA MOB.
ALL OF THEIR ANTI-TRUMP ALLIES.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOW REPORTEDLY
PLANNING TO ANNOUNCE HIS U.S.
SUPREME COURT NOMINATION THIS
WEEKEND AND BREAKING TODAY,
WELL, IT APPEARS THE SENATE WILL
HAVE ENOUGH VOTES TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH EARRINGS AND A VOTE
ON THE PRESIDENT’S NOMINEE.
KEEP IN MIND THERE HAVE BEEN 29
VACANCIES AT THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT DURING
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION YEARS.
A SITTING PRESIDENT HAS
NOMINATED A REPLACEMENT ALL 29
TIMES.
IT WOULD BE UNPRECEDENTED FOR
THIS PRESIDENT NOT TO DO HIS
CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY, NOMINATE A
REPLACEMENT.
AS FAILED PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
AMY KLOBUCHAR ACCURATELY
TWEETING "THE PEOPLE PICK THE
PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT NOMINATES FOR
JUSTICE.
THAT IS HOW IT WORKS."
WELL, AMY, YOU’RE EXACTLY RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
WHEN THE SAME PARTY CONTROLS
BOTH THE WHITE HOUSE AND THE
SENATE, WELL, THE APPROVAL RATE
IS EXCEPTIONALLY HIGH.
17 OUT OF 19 PAST NOMINATIONS
HAVE BEEN CONFIRMED IN THAT
SCENARIO.
THERE IS LITTLE DEMOCRATS CAN DO
OTHER THAN MAKE THREAT AFTER
THREAT AFTER THREAT THAT THESE
THREATS ARE SCARY AND THEY ARE
REAL.
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THEIR
PSYCHOTIC RAGE, THEIR HYSTERIA.
JUST WHEN YOU THINK IT COULDN’T
GET ANY WORSE, THINK AGAIN.
TODAY VERY UNHINGED SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE IN NAME ONLY,
NANCY PELOSI CLAIMING SHE COULD
IMPEACH THIS PRESIDENT EVERY
SINGLE DAY OF THE WEEK.
WOW, THAT’S GOING TO BE SO GOOD
FOR OUR COUNTRY, DON’T YOU
THINK?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT IS YOUR POWER TO DO
THIS?
I GET THE ELECTION.
YOU CAN SPEAK OUT MORE.
YOU CAN DO MORE IMPEACHMENTS,
THINGS LIKE THAT.
DO YOU HAVE ENOUGH POWER?
>> WE CAN IMPEACH HIM EVERY DAY
OF THE WEEK FOR ANYTHING HE
DOES.
>> WHY NOT?
>> 200,000 PEOPLE DYING.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WHAT WE KNOW
WHAT WE ARE DOING THAT AFFECTS
THEM DIRECTLY.
>> Sean: WHILE NANCY PELOSI IS
RANTING AND RAVING ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT, THE MEDIA MOB, THEY
ARE VOWING TO BLOW UP, THEIR
WORDS, THE SYSTEM ALTOGETHER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THINKING ABOUT THE
SUPREME COURT, WE HAVE LOST THAT
BATTLE.
I D DON’T WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
REPUBLICANS ANYMORE.
>> THE FEAR THAT THIS WILL
DESTROY THE SENATE, IT’S LIKE
PEOPLE SAYING CLIMATE CHANGE IS
COMING.
NO, IT’S NOT COMING.
IT’S HERE.
THE SENATE HAS BEEN DESTROYED AS
WE KNOW IT.
>> NOT TAKE MEETINGS WITH THE
NOMINEE.
WE WANT TO SEE THE SENATE
DEMOCRATS FIGHT THIS TOOTH AND
NAIL.
>> NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS,
EVERYBODY STICKS TOGETHER.
>> WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO BLOW
UP THE ENTIRE SYSTEM.
GET RID OF THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE.
THE MINORITY IN THIS COUNTRY
DECIDES WHO THE JUDGES ARE AND
THEY DECIDE WHO THE PRESIDENT
IS.
>> YOU NEED A CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT TO DO THAT.
>> OF JOE BIDEN WINS, DEMOCRATS
CAN STACK THE COURTS AND THEY
CAN DO THAT AMENDMENT THEY CAN
GET IT PASSED.
>> Sean: DO YOU HEAR WHAT THEY
ARE TELLING YOU THEY WANT TO DO?
THE UNETHICAL PRACTICE CALLED
COURT PACKING.
THAT WAS LAST ATTEMPTED BY FDR,
FRANKLIN ROOSEVELT TRIED
UNSUCCESSFULLY TO ADD JUSTICES
TO THE U.S. SUPREME COURT IN
ORDER TO USURP THE POWERS OF THE
DIGITAL BRANCH.
IN OTHER WORDS, ROOSEVELT WAS
TRYING TO EXPAND THE NUMBERS OF
JUSTICES ON THE SUPREME COURT,
FILL SPOTS WITH INDIVIDUALS WHO
JUST RUBBER-STAMP HIS AGENDA.
IN THAT SCENARIO, THE
SUPREME COURT WOULD BECOME
USELESS AND NO LONGER SERVE AS A
COEQUAL BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT.
OUR IMPORTANT CONSTITUTIONAL
SYSTEM OF CHECKS AND BALANCES
WOULD BE COMPLETELY DESTROYED.
ON MONDAY, JOE BIDEN REFUSED TO
SAY WHETHER OR NOT HE SUPPORTS
THE ILLNESS AT PRACTICE OF COURT
PACKING, TELLING A LOCAL
REPORTER "IT’S A LEGITIMATE
QUESTION BUT LET ME TELL YOU WHY
I’M NOT GOING TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION.
IT WILL SHIFT ALL THE FOCUS.
JOE WON’T EVEN RELEASE THE
POTENTIAL SUPREME COURT NOMINEES
HE SAID HE WOULD RELEASE.
JOE DOESN’T ANSWER ANY REAL
QUESTIONS.
PRETTY PATHETIC HOW THE MEDIA
MOB, STATE RUN PAPERS, STATE RUN
BROADCAST TELEVISION, STATE NEWS
CABLE CHANNELS ALSO STATE RUN TV
ALLOW HIM TO GET RID OF ALL
THIS.
MEANWHILE, IS RADICAL FAR LEFT
RUNNING MATE
SENATOR KAMALA HARRIS TELLING
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" SHE IS
ABSOLUTELY OPEN TO PACKING THE
COURT AND MULTIPLE FAR LEFT
MEDIA OUTLETS ARE ALL BUT
BEGGING DEMOCRATS TO INFECT
SUPPORT COURT PACKING, INCLUDING
NEW YORK MAGAZINE, VOX.COM,
RADICAL DEMOCRATS, THE MEDIA
MOB, WELL, THEY DON’T SEEM TO
CARE ABOUT ANY PRECEDENT.
THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTION.
BILL OF RIGHTS.
THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT COEQUAL
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT AND
CHECKS AND BALANCES.
NOW THREATENING TO START
STACKING THE COURTS IN THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE AND THE
LEGISLATIVE FILIBUSTER, IMPEACH
THE PRESIDENT, AS NANCY SAYS
EVERY DAY FOR ANY REASON.
AND OH, YEAH, THEY ALSO WANT TO
IMPEACH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
WHILE THEY ARE ADDED.
DEMOCRATS DO NOT CARE ABOUT OUR
GREAT SYSTEM OF JUSTICE.
THEY WANT TO BURN DOWN THE
SYSTEM AND THEY ARE SAYING SO.
BELIEVE THEM.
FOR THEM, THE ONLY THING THAT
MATTERS IS POWER.
IN 42 DAYS, WELL, ACTUALLY THE
POWER LIES IN YOUR HANDS.
IF IT’S AN HONEST ELECTION, AND
BY THE WAY PART TWO OF MY
MONOLOGUE STRAIGHT AHEAD WILL
COVER THE DEMOCRATS LATEST